This video that you're about to see just
took off on our highlights channel and
it was basically me watching old clips
of my own content like 10, 13 years ago.
Enjoy.
Hey guys, thanks so much for opting in
and taking control. All right? So, what
we're looking for is people who are
super motivated to take our free 6-week
challenge. But, we don't just take
anyone, we take people who are really
motivated and who demonstrated that by
their actions. All right? So, right now
you're actually receiving an email from
me.
>> [snorts]
>> Hey guys, and in your next installment
of the mind game series. Uh I just want
to talk about love versus discipline.
And
it's a topic that I feel like gets
totally misconstrued within the fitness
industry because
trainers will say
>> recording. grit your teeth and get
through it like, you know, he who does
10 more reps will succeed. And uh you
know, eat clean or die trying. And like
all those like fitness memes, like
they're great and whatnot, it's awesome
on the
Dude, this what this is what I'm I
didn't even put a shirt on
and it's a video and I don't look good.
>> [laughter]
>> Hey guys, welcome. Okay, so
[clears throat]
>> [laughter]
>> measuring yourself is a really important
thing to track your progress so that you
can make adjustments to your meal plan.
Make sense?
You want to track as many variables as
you possibly can. The reason for that is
not because you want to see
>> What? Who was recording that?
I don't know.
I don't know. A trainer? Like I have no
idea.
Hey guys, welcome back. I wanted to
record one more video because I love you
a lot and because people ask some really
good questions about bioelectrical
impedance, okay? Body fat measuring
machines, the two that we have. And I
want to explain a little bit more
because the water fluctuation video
today explains a little bit about how we
store water
in our muscles, in our liver, etc. So,
the way that this machine works, let me
show you this guy.
This one. You've seen this one before.
And then uh the handheld machine that we
have the gym is that uh it's
bioelectrical impedance. So, what it
does is it [laughter] actually sends a
little electric shock through you and
then it measures
That's the one I got.
Uh
Are you tired of fitness places that
don't make you have fun or give you the
results you want? Well, United Fitness
is ready to change that. And you know
how? We're going to have you lifting
weights. We're going to have you
following custom nutrition plans in
color.
Hi guys. I'm Alex and I'm the owner of
United Fitness. So, welcome to our
family. Thank you for the opportunity to
earn your business.
So, I just want to tell you a little bit
more about what we do. Uh United
Fitness, we strive to be the leading
body and life transformation business
out there. For men and women who want to
Dude, so [__] tough. Hey dudes, good
morning. Um I hope everyone's crushing
their goals and accomplish what they
want. I was just
I've just been a part of a bunch of
masterminds recently and with the little
campaign that we got going on here in
DC, I'm actually driving in right now.
Um I was just I was kind of thinking
about some stuff cuz
um
planning
versus executing.
Um
You know, you should you do it.
>> It's just it becomes abundantly clear if
you start sitting in on like
higher income type circles of people who
are doing really well and people who are
really achieving things is that
a lot of times it's like there's like
there's no secret. It's just
how many people like
to what extent you're executing. Like
that's it, you know? Um you set out with
a plan and then you execute. And the
thing is it's like that plan doesn't
need to be um
really, really detailed and most of the
time it's because bars Gosh, I can't
remember. It's like it's there's a
German general, but what he said was um
no plan survives first contact with the
enemy. And so, I'm not saying
you know, what you're doing is the enemy
or who you're working with is the enemy,
but
you're going to change it the moment you
actually start doing something. So, just
don't obsess over about it. Like don't
overanalyze cuz it's just not going to
even be what you think it is anyways.
You know, like I changed my I don't even
know. six times before I finally figured
out what was working and I I guarantee
you it wasn't like I wouldn't have
figured it out unless I like actually
just did it and had people
you know, to actually train.
Uh so
pretty uh
just a just something to like I guess
take into consideration
>> through the video and that sounds like
I'm rapping.
Then I'm like uh And if you're if you're
trying to build something or trying to
make a new product or trying to make a
new service or figure out how to how to
launch A lot of times just find the
customer, sell them on the fact that
you're going to help them in some
meaningful way and and that you're not
going to leave until they're satisfied
with like that you like me
help them Two minutes
two and a half minutes to get there.
I've recently started a different
service where I actually help gyms
launch
and I just do it for free. I go in and I
just launch the gyms and basically we
would just kind of split up
what I can bring in for the gym. And
before I actually had the service,
someone was I saw me speak and they were
like, "Dude,
can you like just can I buy something
from you?"
>> [laughter]
>> Um I was like, "Sure, like I don't
know." Like
He was like, "How much is it going to
be?" I was like, "I don't know, we'll
figure it out." And uh and so I ended up
just going down and I promised like I'll
just help you make more money at your
gym. And he was like, "Cool, like just
sign me up." So, so it was like the
weirdest, funniest sale I'd ever done
from the stage. But uh
But anyways, all that to say
um it's actually sprouted the entire new
business and a lot of that happened just
in the last month by launching three
different gyms this month. Kind of going
fire ain't ready. Like I'll go in and I
know that I can deliver value and help
you make more money and help you
operate, you know, more leanly.
Um
And so, yeah. So, anyways, sorry I just
stunned everyone's eyes,
but I hope everyone's freaking crushing
their goals and I will talk to you guys
soon.
Easy. Bye. Hey guys, real quick. Many of
you guys are getting started in business
and don't know, but other entrepreneurs
have already tried to help. And so, 3.6
million copies were donated by other
entrepreneurs in my book launch and I'm
donating these books as well. And so, if
you're starting in business and you
would like the ultimate business
backpack, all three books. This one
shows you how to figure out what to
sell, this shows you how to get people
to find out about it and this one shows
you how to make money from it. When you
have all three, you can actually get
started. All right? On top of that, you
have 30 days of school that you can get
absolutely free and all of this,
including the books, including school,
including shipping is 16 bucks. Yeah,
like we lose money on this. So, go grab
it.
It's the ultimate thing I can give you,
my gift. Enjoy. If you go there and it's
shut down, it's cuz we ran out, but as
long as the link still works, there's
books.